you got pissed off at that um the rumor
that all of a sudden that there was a
band being formed you your your uncle
um i think it was sammy they were saying
online
and um i don't know who else was
supposed to be oh that michael anthony
was going to play bass and you were
going to play lead
but i was going to replace my dad and
van halen that's [ __ ] stupid
right you can't have van halen
without eddie van halen i'm not my dad
i'm not going to replace him
you know i i've spent my life making
sure i'm not like him and i'm my own
person my and my dad again he'd be
pissed off he'd be like what the [ __ ]
are you doing go do your [ __ ]
right who starts those rumors
desperate fans which i understand they
they they want to see the music
continue but
some things just suck and this is one of
those things
you can't have van halen without eddie
van halen
so you know in my opinion outside of
maybe a a a tribute show at some point
down the line and you know archival
releases
further down the line it's done
you're right you can't have that without
him
but you know what i don't have a dad
anymore
and i'm coming to terms with that and
i'm trying to figure out how to deal
with that so i think the fans can try
and come to terms with
and figure out how to deal with the fact
that we're not going to have van halen
anymore
the music is going to live on forever
but you can't continue
without eddie van halen
you